says camilla
[Music]
you pronounced my name wrong calls me
camelot carmichael why is it so hard for
him camila caballo is dishing out the
disses to blake shelton over his country
twang
of course it's all in the name of
friendly competition as camilla is the
newest coach to join the voice for
season 22.
please help me you and gwen would make a
great team what the i want the best for
him no you don't you want the worst for
me vote can be true we don't blame
camilla for roasting blake in a new
promo for the singing competition show
she's probably giving blake a hard time
because the country crooner was up to
his usual antics just two weeks ago when
this promo dropped
you are going to lose so bad
who would send that
i can't believe you got that
anonymous letter it's pretty clear who
the anonymous note came from but by the
end of the clip blake's secret was
uncovered hey blake can you please stop
crafting in my dressing room
busted
of course camilla's the new kid on the
block this season taking kelly
clarkson's seat and joining returning
coaches blake john and gwen stefani i
mean i'm so excited nick jonas and
shakira previously served as coaches and
when it spoke with them in may they
shared some words of wisdom for camilla
camille caballo joining the boys she's
going to kill it yeah
there's nothing like being a part of the
voice family i think she'll have a great
time i would say to her careful with
blake sheldon
it's a running joke between the coaches
since team blake has been racking up
wins and took home the crown with season
20's winner
cam anthony
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen and all
of our finalists tonight
just ignore him just ignore him like
he's not even there
blake we love you
solid advice to keep her eye on the
prize we have a feeling team camilla
will bring some stiff competition i want
the best for him no you don't you want
the worst for me both can be true